the next thing I know
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
we stood right in front of the elevator
the Lisa and I and 18 other people from
my office these are all big shots the
head of Human Resources
the general manager all these big shots
they're standing up right there
not a word is said the elevator doors
open we got in
here
[Music]
as I'm getting out of the door the
security guard looks at me and says
where you going
I said I'm going home I saw Fireballs
falling from the other building
he said your building is safe secure go
back to your office
you can hear the whoop whoop signals
your building is safe it's secure go
back to your office
nobody else is coming out
the least stepped out
as you said Stan I'm scared I want to go
home I said well
take the rest of the day off
I had that choice to go back into that
elevator at that point or go home
so I don't know what to do
the doors are about to close and Jack
Andrei accio is holding on to one end
and Manny Gomez is holding on to the
other end come on Stan the Man
you're not scared to go back up
come on stand we don't have all day here
and I walk back in that elevator
[Music]
and all I was doing was being faithful
to Authority they said go back all right
so we go back
the door closes and I can still remember
to look at the faces of everybody in
that elevator
because I was the last one who stepped
in and everybody's looking at me like
why did you take so long we were waiting
on you
not realizing I would never see them
again
[Music]
thank you
we saw a lot of things that day that
no one should see
to this day I still have my times when I
can't take it anymore you know and I
still think about it
there were times when I would go over
the Brooklyn Bridge going into work and
it just got me so bad that I I couldn't
take it anymore and there was as I was
driving over the bridge I actually felt
myself almost trying to jerk the wheel
off to decide to just drive off the edge
of the bridge just so I didn't have to
deal with it anymore
you know and every time I did that I was
like you can't do this you know you just
keep going just keep going you can do
this
[Applause]
I've worked as an immersion medical
technician
I was young 21 year old kid
and we were driving down to the Trade
Center to help people
as we pull up
we see hundreds of people just running
out to us and you're just looking
through and you don't know where to go
because there's just so much chaos going
on
thank you
[Applause]
and and remember as I was grabbing my
equipment to go see what we were going
to do
some people kept on running up to me and
like you gotta help my friend you gotta
help my friend I'm like okay I'm like
calm down I'm like where is your friend
what happened they jumped like from
where
from the 30th floor from up there I'm
like they're dead the bridge is that way
just run
[Music]
grab the first four or five people that
we saw that had blood on them and we run
them to the back of our ambulance
the rules almost went out the window
that day you did what you could for who
you could
hey can you look out your window right
now
can you say God about 4 000 feet about
five east Europe right now
yeah Hi Sam
is he the same for the billion also
he's ascending really quick too yeah
4 500 feet now he gets to drop to 800
feet in like a like once One Sweep
that's another situation
[Music]
I'm on the 81st floor and the South
Tower in a huge glass enclosed office
the phone is ringing
I pick up the phone it's a young lady
from Chicago on the other end Stan get
out
why do I have to get out
with the phone in my hand I'm standing
up not looking in any particular
direction but something caught my
attention looking towards the direction
of the Statue of Liberty South
what I saw was a tiny little speck force
of a plane and within the Split Second
is getting larger and larger and larger
oh my God it's coming towards I mean
it's coming for me I love light contact
and I have some watching within split
seconds I can see this plane start
tilting
very gradually and I'm watching this
plane like being hypnotized can't move
my eyes away and I can hear him can hear
this revving sound this engine is making
like when the plane takes off that sound
that it's making well multiply that by a
thousand and the spring is coming
towards me
I mean my mind is reacting so fast and I
don't know what to do and the next thing
I Remember by saying and I don't know
why I said I said Lord I can't do this
you take over trap the phone's cream
Dove under the desk
oh
[Applause]
my God oh my God
a second airplane a 727 just ran into
the building
[Music]
where do I go do I go home
hello Joe yo I'm gonna get out of the
city
[Music]
[Laughter]
when the plane hit I got blown out of my
shoes and I hit the marble wall in front
of me with my upper body
and then my strong will or my abstinence
kicked in I'm like oh no way I am not
offering my kids in this building I am
getting out of here
[Music]
we got into the stairwells and we
stumbled across this gentleman who had
artificial legs um and he sat down and
said I can't go anymore that two men
just had no way not on our watch and
they picked them up and they just
started carrying them down I encountered
a woman on the stairwell who was having
an asthma attack and in my pocketbook I
had an inhaler and I handed it to her I
said here just use it and she was using
it and she said oh my God I can breathe
and she started down so you just did
everybody was just
doing what they needed to do to help it
was a constant very quick flow but
people were kind to each other
[Music]
we were like right in the path of all
the debris from the second plane and
from the building
and it was just shot right towards our
ambulance
while the patients they were all huddled
on the floor all crunched together with
their hands over their heads and we were
just kind of on top of them
we were scared now I mean at least like
I know I can't speak for anybody else
but I can speak for myself I was
terrified
I looked at my partner and I said you
know we we need to get out of here
when we pulled out of there
I hear him scream through the front I'm
getting flagged I'm being flagged
so I open up the back doors and I'm like
what's going on he's like this guy
jumped in front of the ambulance he said
we need to help this lady
so I'm like all right so we jump out and
we see this one lady she was lying half
on the street half on the sidewalk
Orlando and I were able to just move her
over to the side a little bit and we saw
that her whole backside looked like it
was just torn off from her shoulder
blades all the way down to like the top
of her thigh it looked like everything
was just ripped right off
um we didn't know it at the time but we
found out later on
that she was hit by the landing gear of
the second plane and it went right down
and ripped off half her back
[Applause]
[Music]
as we're driving
she was screaming out in agony
[Music]
I remember seeing every the three or
four other patients in the ambulance you
know and you can see them that they're
scared they were all crying they were
all looking around like and they're
looking at me
here I am 21 year old kid what do I know
and I remember the woman on the
stretcher I go down and she's awake and
she's looking at me and she's screaming
she's like it hurts I'm I'm hurt help me
somebody please help me
and I remember just getting down on my
knee
and just holding her hand and getting
close to her I'm like it's all right
it's okay we got you I'm like I'm here
now I'm gonna get you to the hospital
you know we're gonna we're gonna take
care of you
[Music]
there was a bunch of doctors just
waiting for us at the door
they start grabbing some of the other
patients that we brought in and other
people and we're like no no forget those
like this one you got to take this one
in right here
you know just handing the patient over
it's like okay I've I've done my part I
did my part I did what I did the best
that I could for her and I brought it to
people that can help her a lot more than
I can
[Music]
[Applause]
I really thought I died
Here I Am Alive
this is not possible
about impact
a large chunk of that plane was stuck in
the office doorway the air pressure was
so great it was sucking everything out
it looks like a demolition crew came and
just ripped the entire floor apart every
wall is flattened every piece of
furniture is mangled I'm hiding on that
desk
it looks like somebody took a giant bag
of cement and throw it in the air
the jet fuel is smelling so profusely
the sun was so deafening that my ears
pop
I got temporarily deaf
all the cables that were hanging in the
ceiling track and they short circuit
thing the sprinkler system came on
and part of the floor collapsed and it's
hovering like this right over the desk
if I don't get burned well then I'll get
electrocuted
if I don't get electrocuted and burn
well then the floor is going to collapse
I'm gonna die I'm gonna get crushed
and then the three of them miss me well
then I'm gonna get sucked over by the
air pressure one way that I'm gone
and I started to scream
when the second tower got hit
that was a terrifying moment
because now you realize this this is no
accident this is intentional and that
changes
your whole perception of what you're
dealing with now
one of my thoughts was going through my
head is stay calm
uh you know uh you have to make I knew I
was going to be having to make some very
serious uh decisions involving people's
lives
which is my job which I'm trained for
and they trained very well for on the
fire department and I wanted to make it
with a it's clear ahead as I could so I
had to I had to avoid that the the
little panicky thing that you go through
with at first
[Music]
I was climbing the stairs in the North
Tower
and our orders were to report to the
23rd floor
so I'm walking around the floor I'm
looking for this Chief I'm supposed to
report to
and I hear the chatter I I hear people
talking
and of course I'm curious where what is
nobody's supposed to be there and I
opened the door and there's two people
inside the stairway
it was an injured secretary a woman and
her boss
stayed with her this is an incredibly
heroic guy I wish I could remember his
name but he stayed and took his in
trying to get his injured secretary out
of the building and they were in
Stairway to see no they were alone there
was nobody else in Stairway to see and I
was worried about them so I told him go
to steroid B the fire departments and
Stairway to be they will help you
and they they were frozen they couldn't
move they just froze and then I yelled
at them
I felt bad but I yelled at them I was
good you know God stay away
I'm gonna tell you again you smell like
that but I had to do it you know because
I had to startle them to get them out of
that they were in like a a funk you know
I mean it was so and finally they
listened to me they went over the
stairway Bay so and they survived they
got out
that was good
[Music]
Virginia
to help anybody you got to start
triaging
you try to
determine
the injury
at a second moment so that the unit
coming behind you can immediately treat
that person
[Music]
Wing tag for the minor
injuries you can understand everything
then you have the red tag for immediate
and then when we get to the disease that
means
no care needed
at this time this person is presumed
dead
I was underneath the towers going from
area to area
I did not see
any living person
on the ground
everybody was deceased
[Music]
so going past you just rip the tags off
the left deceased disease until
I ran into that one person
I'd put
deceased which is a black tag
and as she says I'm not
dead
call my daughter
but she didn't know what I knew and she
didn't see what I see
her head did not hit the ground or I
couldn't see that the head was of course
the hair
was still intact she looked like an
office person now she looked like maybe
a woman that was on the plane
and her makeup
but what I saw below the Torso
was
completely crushed
it's figured
meant
[Music]
this lady must have came down feet first
I could have done
something immediately to help her
but I was panicking myself
I was dealing with death
myself
even though I did not fear death or I
wasn't thinking about death but I saw
death and I saw a deaf and I saw a deaf
and I do that
she would not survived another couple of
minutes
[Music]
so
I lied
he says you're okay
this is preliminary this is just
I I meant to react I tore the wrong
thing off relax they're coming they're
coming they're coming
don't worry about what I just did
[Music]
I had to go conscious about what I was
saying and uh and that I was lying but I
wasn't lying in the fact of her
condition
I was lying in the fact that I did think
she was dead
[Music]
oh
and that black tag
stayed with me
it took me three years to push it back
or from this cortex part of my brain to
the frontal part of my brain the memory
or put it somewhere
with the psychiatrist
and the clinician that helped me move
her around
so that she's not in the mind's eye in
the daytime or in the night time
or at any time
the human body or the human mind is not
a physician or the brain can never be
positioned to deal with tragedy of
another human being
it just reminds you that this is could
be your mother
it's your father this is your family
this is a human being
you don't lie to
dying
[Music]
foreign
I came out on the 44th floor because
that's where our stairwell ends and
there was panic in Bedlam and it was
Pitch Black
and then all of a sudden in this
darkness is this voice he was singing
and I think the singing distracted
everybody that they were they stopped in
their tracks to see why he was singing
or where he was singing from and it
calmed everybody down and then he said
these words he said today is a proud day
to be an American
[Music]
it was Rick roscola our head of security
Rick was so concerned for many years
about the security and safety of
everybody in the World Trade Center it
had been attacked before and he was
certain it would happen again
he did predict that they would come if
they came again that they would come
from the air and it's very hard to
protect people when they come from the
air so the only protection would be to
teach them how to get out in case a
catastrophe happened
[Music]
Rick had them redo the stairwells
repaint them make sure there was
lighting so everybody could see where we
were going
and four times a year we walked from 70
all the way down to the sky Lobby to get
out of the building
you know at first people would just
assume this is over the top it was
exaggerated it was do we really need to
do this I mean in my mind my favorite
line was lightning never strikes the
same place twice so after 93 I didn't
even think about it because I was like
no one's ever going to attack the same
building again
foreign
[Music]
that day things were on fire you know
things are blowing up and he really was
able to refocus everybody pretty quickly
and disperse the crowds to the proper
stairwells to get them out of there so
seeing Rick was probably like senior
Guardian Angel when I saw him on 44.
I wasn't nervous at that point I really
wasn't
tell your grandchildren you were there
you were there
[Music]
I wasn't emotional on that day
I was not frozen in fear I wasn't
thinking horrible thoughts
my mind thankfully protected me from
absorbing any Carnage now I you know my
mind blocked
anything that might have been really
ugly out there I I don't remember other
than this grayness others died and I
didn't I wasn't having any of that in my
mind yet
again I cannot explain why
um I and I I keep wondering you know
well am I you know
am I cold-hearted I don't I don't think
so I think I'm tender and and
compassionate when I need to be
odd
[Music]
that was stuck in the 81st floor
I crawled the entire length of the loans
department or the lounge in the computer
room in the communication room and
that's the farthest I could have gone
because one lousy sheetrock wall stood
Farm it's one wall
that period of waiting was the most
painful thing
you would ever imagine that period of
just waiting hoping that somebody is
going to come to get you and I'm crying
out to this invisible God that I've hurt
so much
[Music]
from the 84th floor I led a group of
people down the stairs
and we arrived on the 81st floor me and
the lead as I arrived there a heavyset
woman came up and stopped me we've just
come off a floor in flames and smoke and
we've got to go higher and of course I'm
stopped now and can't get past her and
bumping behind me comes the rest of my
team if you like so now there's this
group of us nine ten people on the 81st
floor Landing who are now beginning the
debate listening to her and starting to
discuss well do we go up do we go down
what do we do now
[Music]
I'm behind of a wall
and I'm crying out wait for me don't
leave me to die
[Music]
foreign
was something like help help I'm buried
is anyone there I can't breathe kind of
again sobered up and said okay I've got
a job to do here and my flashlight back
on again and as I squeezed onto that
floor sideways I have this very very
clear memory of everybody on the on that
Landing turning around and starting to
go up the stairs
so I started toward the stranger's voice
I can only hear that voice faintly
I had my hand through that hole and I'm
trying please please my hand is here
turn to your left as I hear a little bit
his voice is walking away his voice is
moving away from me no no come back come
back towards your right come back come
back towards your left come straight
straight straight now as I can hear this
voice Closer Closer sharper look down
look down look down
here I am with my hand
waving towards him when that light flash
in my hand all hope was there
somebody this person with his flashlight
whoever it is somebody's gonna rescue me
I'm gonna live it was that hope
that feeling of knowing that you know
what I'm gonna live
that feeling of knowing that you're
gonna live that somebody is here to take
you home
I'm gonna get to see my children again
I'm gonna be reconciled my wife again
I'm gonna live they left me here to die
but I'm gonna go home
and this man really did that
rescued me so I could go home
[Music]
Hallelujah I've been saved he said one
thing I gotta know do you know Jesus
Christ
that was a very strange thing to hear at
that time and I wasn't ready for a
philosophical discussion so I I
stammered out a rather pathetic reply uh
I go to church every Sunday that was the
best I could do to that question and I
come out we got work to do here so there
was a lot of debris to the right a
debris to the left of me and this
immovable wall between us and I told him
that the only way out of there is for
you to come up this wall
so he tried once and I missed him
I said you must do this and over the
wall he came and then his weight on me
pushed the desk over we fell back onto a
pile of debris and he gave me a big kiss
and he got up he says what are you doing
fix this jacket in his tie
and his stretch his hand he says Brian
Clark
I said Stanley premier
he said I'm Stanley he said we'll be
brothers for life and I said well I have
no siblings I said we can be brothers
and then I noticed I had a puncture
wound on my right palm and Stanley also
had a puncture wound on his bomb and I'm
the one who did it I put our hands
together and said we'll be blood
brothers for life and we made our way
off the floor back to the 81st floor
Landing
I Shine the Light down and I took that I
didn't see Flames I saw some smoke
coming up
and I took that
gratefully took that fateful first step
down and we continued on down
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
second floor of the Integrity of the
building was really starting to
deteriorate and then there was cracks
starting in the walls and this and you
know we were like holy crap we have to
get out of here and we really started to
pick up the pace like almost running and
all I kept thinking is this building's
not taking me I'm going home to my kids
so I kept going and going
and when we got to the bottom floor we
were yelling we're here we're here and
some people were clapping and they're
like all right we're right behind you
[Music]
thank you
when we emerged out of the building
there was a sense of relief that we were
safe
[Music]
they ushered us across the street
my little group we sat down on the curb
[Music]
and they were triaging right behind us
they were carrying very wounded people
behind us laying them down trying to
triage what they could do
[Music]
when we looked up and saw the burning on
our building my first thought was this
is coming down
I'm not going to die here on the street
I just got out of that building I have
to get out of here
some of the people we work with
encountered Rick on one of the lower
floors as they were leaving the building
Rick was heading up the stairs
and they said Rick come with us and he's
like no no I have to do one more sweep
to make sure all our people are safe
he could have gotten out
but he chose to go back up
well I knew that Rick was doing what
Rick was destined to do and that was get
everybody out of that building and
knowing Rick you knew he wasn't leaving
until that last person was out
the ash filled the air and blocked the
Sun
and very strangely as we went down
Broadway and it wasn't densely populated
all of a sudden Stanley was gone I I'm
looking around wondering where he is and
this feeling washed over me like oh
did I just imagine this was Stanley some
sort of a guardian angel like I had real
confused doubts about what had just
transpired I learned later from Stanley
that he had commandeered a guy in a
pickup truck and told him you drive me
to Brooklyn that apparently the guy did
Brian said to me later on had he made
the choice to go back up like the others
he would have died but there was
something in that scream that held him
to help me
so every time I tell this man Brian
thank you for saving my life he says to
understand thank you that had you not
screamed I would have gone back up I
would have died
[Music]
oh
being as young as I was at the time
that day um definitely changed me
you know there are things that I live
with to this day that still haunt my
dreams from it
[Music]
you know when I started thinking about
on how bad it could be
I keep thinking of that patient
that we picked up
the woman on the stretcher we didn't
think that she was going to make it
through at all but we found out a couple
weeks later
that she was still alive
[Music]
this is mag for magnificent
I got him last night from a friend of my
fiance's
he is so much fun I normally there's
only white blankets here and then I got
mad last night too that it it made me
realize that collar has been absence in
my environment and it showed up when it
really needed to be there so and I found
that later on her name was Debbie
I remember going to the hospital to go
see her
and they brought us over to her room and
she was still intubated at the time but
she was sitting up unconscious and she's
looking at us and you see how moving her
hand and she's like it's that it's them
she was pointing to us and all the
people that we walked by in the waiting
room was her parents her fiance and the
rest of her family they came over to us
and they were just hugging us
okay
you know and it became it was very
emotional for Orlando and I
the EMT truck that allowed me to get on
it
the few times that I was able to see her
in the hospital she was always upbeat
she's like don't worry I'm gonna get
better
and throughout my time she has been an
inspiration for me to get me out of my
Dark Places knowing the fact that I gave
someone back their family I helped bring
that person back home
oh
our orders were to go upstairs in the
North Tower for search and rescue and uh
we heard a loud noise outside
and I see
Billy bark walking towards me he's got a
funny look on his face and uh
I look at him and I says is that what I
thought it was thinking that a piece of
our building fell off
and he just looks at me and he says
South Towers just collapsed
knowing what that meant that
right next door to us thousands of
people were just killed
some of our friends too
and
I did the quick calculations in my mind
and I says all right if that one can go
this one can go it's time for us to get
out of here and
my guys didn't react they walked
they didn't want to leave
and I said let's go it's time to go
so we start our Retreat down the B
stairway of the North Tower
and I'd just be whispering at the Billy
Butler's ears says Billy can you move a
little faster
[Music]
and the uh
collapse of the North Tower starts with
us still inside
[Music]
thank you